- [Instructor] Our world is
extraordinarily complicated.
So in physics we're going to
have to make simplifications.
Even things in our world that seems simple
are extraordinarily complicated.
So consider a basketball
seems simple enough,
but it's composed of an
extraordinarily large number
of air molecules bouncing
around inside, colliding
with the outside leather
and rubber membrane,
which itself is composed of an
extraordinarily large number
of atoms and molecules all bonded together
holding on tight, trying
to prevent themselves
from being ripped apart and
exploded by the pressure inside.
So do we have to keep track
of every atom and molecule
in this ball to include
it in a physics problem?
Typically not, nor would
we ever really want to.
I mean, we can't keep track
of all that info, not yet,
nor would you want to for most scenarios.
So for instance, if you were an astronaut,
you went to the moon,
you took your basketball and
you were going to drop it.
If all you wanted to know
was how long it's gonna take
for this ball to strike
the lunar surface below,
you don't need to know
about the ideal gas law,
you don't need to know about
the structural integrity
of the rubber leather membrane.
You could solve this by
treating the basketball
as if there was no internal
structure whatsoever.
Like you were dropping a rock that had
no interesting internal
structure whatsoever.
So in physics, the good
news is we can typically get
away with making a lot of simplifications
and ignoring the internal structure
if it isn't relevant to the
problem that we're asking.
Sometimes it will be relevant though.
So here was a case where
it wasn't relevant.
The internal structure wasn't relevant.
So we could ignore that
internal structure,
but other questions like
if you were an astronaut,
I mean if I was an
astronaut, and I was bringing
my basketball to the moon,
I'd be like, wait a minute,
there's no atmosphere on the moon.
That means there is no pressure
pushing in from the outside.
That means all this air
pressure's still pushing
out from the inside is my
basketball just gonna explode?
I'd want to know this before
I brought it out there.
I don't wanna carry a little bomb out
that's going to like blow up in my face
and I don't want to lose a basketball.
If you wanted to know if your basketball
was going to explode,
okay now it does depend.
That question does depend
on the internal structure.
It depends on the pressure inside
which is fundamentally related
to the force of the collisions
between these air molecules
and the rubber membrane and
then it depends also on,
well, how strong are the bonds
between these rubber membrane
and leather molecules?
How much force can they
withstand before they burst?
For that question you
would have to consider
the internal structure.
So, in some questions you get to ignore
the internal structure and
other questions you don't.
It's just context and question-dependent
and in physics, we have
terminology to sort of
sort this out and the
terminology we use is the idea
of a system or the idea of an object.
So the idea of a system
is just a collection
of objects, that's the definition
of a system in physics.
But that begs the question,
well what do we mean by an object?
By an object, we mean
anything that you could treat
as if it had no internal structure.
We don't mean that objects
have no internal structure.
They typically do, the only
things that don't truly
have an internal structures
as far as we know
are truly fundamental particles
like electrons or neutrinos,
these fundamental particles
in particle physics
that as far as we know,
have no internal structure.
So unless you're doing particle physics,
you're probably don't have a true object,
but you can treat things like an object.
We can treat this
basketball like an object.
That is to say, we can act as if it has
no internal structure if
that internal structure
isn't relevant to the problem.
So to make this a little more meaningful
just imagine another example.
Say you collide two objects
so you collide a putty here.
Let's say this is three kilogram object
and it comes in with a certain speed
and it collides with a
five kilogram object.
If all you want to know is
when they stick together,
say these stick together and move off
with some common speed.
If all you want to know is
what is that common speed
that they move off with
after they stick together?
Notice what you don't need to know.
I don't need to tell
you that this was made
out of gold here or that this
one was made out of copper
as long as you know, the masses and that
they stick together,
physics will let you solve
for how fast they'll move off
with a common speed afterward
if you tell me that they stick together.
So if that's all you want to know
doesn't matter what the
internal structure is.
However, for other questions,
if you wanted to know
if this was going to set off
some nuclear explosion, okay
well then it really is going
to matter if these are made
out of gold, made out of
copper, made out of clay
or if they're made out
of uranium, so to speak.
So for that question, you do need to know
about the internal structure.
So the idea of a system and the idea
of an object is an
important one in physics
and it's not just important
conceptually or abstractly
it can actually help
you in problem solving.
So let me show you a more
like, tangible example
of where this might help you
in solving a problem you might encounter
in your physics courses.
So let's say they're two boxes
and they're just too big
and unwieldy to handle.
So you're going to push
them across the floor.
They're not heavy, they're just
like shaped weird, let's say
and let's say the floor
has been newly waxed.
So it's real slick against these boxes
which are also slick and
there's negligible friction.
You could ignore the
friction between the boxes
and the floor, so let's say you come up
and you're gonna push on these things.
Push them into the
corner of some warehouse,
you're working in the
warehouse here, earning
your pay for the day
and you're going to go
push these over here and
you're going to exert,
let's just say nine newtons of force
on this one kilogram
box and then that pushes
into the two kilogram box
and they move off to the right.
So can we treat this system
of boxes as if it were a single object?
Well, like we said,
it's question-dependent.
If the question we want to ask
is, what's the acceleration
of these boxes as they slide to the right?
Well, they're going to
move at the same rate
because as you push on
this one kilogram box
that one kilogram box pushes
on the two kilogram box
and they're going to move together.
As I keep pushing with nine
newtons, the velocity of both
of these boxes are going
to be the same to the right
and the acceleration of the boxes
are going to be the same to the right.
They're never going to become separated.
What that means is the fact
that there were two boxes
didn't matter, I can treat
this system of two boxes
as if it were a single three kilogram box.
I don't even need to know
that they were actually
a division here, 'cause
they're never going to become
separated for this question
that I'm asking here.
So I could treat this whole system
as if it were just one
big three kilogram object
and this is an important idea.
The properties of a system,
like the mass of the
system, are determined
by the properties of the
objects in that system.
So I put a three here and this
is legal, this is allowed.
The properties of this total
mass of my system is determined
by the mass of the individual
objects in my system.
So you really can just add up these masses
to determine the total mass of the system
that you're going to be
treating as a single object.
And now that I get to treat
this as a single object
I'm in luck, I can use
Newton's second law.
The acceleration is going
to equal the net force
over the mass, we'll do this
for the horizontal direction.
I'm just going to put a mass of three.
I could ignore the fact
that this was a one and two
and the total mass of
my system is going to be
three kilograms and the
only force on my system
that I'm treating as an object here
is the nine Newton force.
I could ignore, in other words,
I can ignore the internal
forces between these boxes.
I don't care about the
one pushing on the two
or the two pushing on the
one I'm treating the system
like an object and I'm ignoring
that internal structure
that makes this problem really easy
when I solve for the acceleration
I just get three meters
per second squared.
So for this question I
could treat the system
as a single object.
What question would I not
be able to treat the system
as a single object for?
Well, if I wanted to know,
let's say the question was
with how much force does
the one kilogram box exert
on the two kilogram box?
And you might think, oh,
it's just nine, but it isn't.
So stay tuned, hold on.
It's counterintuitive. I know,
but the main idea I'm
trying to stress here
is that this force on two
by one is fundamentally
a question about an internal force.
So if the question you're asking is about
the internal structure,
clearly you're not allowed
to ignore the internal structure.
So for this question we
cannot treat the system
of two boxes as if it were a single mass.
We'll have to focus on
the internal structure.
So again, consider this a
one and a two separate boxes
and we'll do the same formula.
Acceleration's going to equal
the net force over the mass,
but this time we do have
to focus on a single mass.
So we'll focus just on
the two kilogram mass
the only horizontal force
on this two kilogram mass
if this really is frictionless
is this force that we want to
find the force onto by one.
And that's the only force that's exerted
on the two kilogram mass.
This nine newtons is
exerted directly on the one.
So it's not directly exerted on the two.
We don't draw that up here.
We don't include that here.
These are only forces
directly on the two, and then
we'd have to put the acceleration
of the two kilogram mass,
but we already found that this
three was the acceleration
of the one, the two and the entire system.
Everything was accelerating
at the same rate.
So I can put my three meters
per second squared here
and I find out that the force exerted
on the two by the one is six newtons.
So it's not as big and
this isn't surprising.
It takes more newtons from the left here
this nine newtons to
accelerate the entire system
of three kilograms than it does to just
accelerate the two
kilogram mass over here.
So the fact that this force
is accelerating less mass
means it doesn't have to be as big.
But the key idea is that to find that,
we could not treat, to
find this force here,
we could not treat this entire
system as a single mass.
So recapping, if the question
being asked does not depend
on the internal structure,
you can simplify your life
by treating that structure and that system
as if it were a single
object, in which case,
the properties of that will be determined
by the properties of the
objects in that system.
But if the question being
asked does depend on
the internal structure,
then you cannot treat
that system as a single object.
You will have to focus on
the internal structure.